her hair is long and black her nails
sharp
she thirsts for blood once vibrant alive
and pregnant
she's none of those things anymore the
pontianak are
southeast asia's infamous vampiric
mothers
a staple of malay folklore thriving even
today
they share their name with the city in
indonesia in fact the city was actually
named
after the monster there are a lot of
female monsters who use femininity as a
weapon
but this one is the first i've seen
whose monstrous nature is directly
associated with pregnancy and childbirth
but why does this gruesomely powerful
vampiric specter of maternity gone awry
haunt the jungle what is her story and
why is there a need for this sort of
monster
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
the ghost of a woman who died tragically
while pregnant or during childbirth the
pontiac seeks revenge against those who
were involved in her death
known alternatively as the kunti lanak
this type of vengeful maternal specter
haunts a vast region
including modern day malaysia indonesia
singapore
brunei all the way down to the southern
regions of the philippines and thailand
which means a lot of people share the
stories of this monster
both pontianak and kutilinak end in the
malay
word meaning child emphasizing they are
literally
named and defined by their connection to
children and childbirth
nourished by human blood and organs
especially from children
the pontinoc live in trees and if you
dare go out walking alone at night
you might see them stalking prey from
the branches above
the favorite habitat of the pontianak is
also part of its name
it said that the ponte in pontianak
originates from the malay phrase for
tall tree or tall trees although these
monsters manifest as vampiric ghosts
the pontianak can disguise herself in
the physical form of a beautiful young
woman
who seems fragile and delicate a facade
she uses to lure her victims
in in both human and ghost form the long
flowing black hair of the creature
creates a stark contrast against its
white robes
when in their spectral form they are
vicious and gruesome
you can hear them swooshing or making a
rustling sound like
leaves crackling as they glide through
the sky followed by a loud shrieking
sound
right before attacking and drinking the
blood of the victim
they may use their long fingernails or
fangs to create a wound from which they
suck the blood of their prey
some say these ghost's hair covers a
hole in the back of their necks
the last thing you will see as you
succumb to an attack is the scars of a
snarling scowling face
as she goes in for the kill the ponte
knock is a tortured female body in part
because it is trapped between the
warring influences
of islam and traditional malay culture
and religious practices
islam arrived in southeast asia as early
as the 9th century through arabic
traders
but the religion did not have a dramatic
influence in this part of the world
until the 12th century ce
muslim settlements arose as the trade
routes were solidified
and eventually led to the conversion of
various monarchies to islam and the
first sultans of the region
of course anytime you introduce a
religion and new rulers you get tension
with existing beliefs often manifesting
in conflict between perceived modernity
and indigenous culture
the pontianak is one such example in
islamic ideals the female body is
heteropatriarchal
in deep contrast with the more
egalitarian malay indigenous
gender traditions but the very thing
that defines the identity of a woman
in both cultures motherhood is what
enables the supernatural existence of
these ghosts
the pontianak is both seductive and
repulsive a creature to desire
and fear she is monstrously feminine
not all women who die during childbirth
or while pregnant become a pontiac
only those who suffer at the hands of
men that is one of the defining aspects
of this monster the unhappy death in the
pontiac stories
is defining aspect of the monster and is
brought on by sexual or physical
violence during pregnancy or outright
murder
so this tormented ghost woman embodies
two of the most defining fears in much
of women's history
patriarchal violence and the dangers of
childbirth
in their ghostly form ponte knock are
strong scale tall trees and
fly a nail or stake driven into the back
of the neck
subdues the monster forcing it into its
human form
and making it the slave of the assailant
often with a transformation into a
dutiful
quiet mother and wife removing the nail
allows her to turn back into her
ghost form but she cannot do this
herself not just a representation of
women's status in the malay and islamic
cultures out of which it arose
pontianak play a part in the history of
the very civilizations of the people who
share its story
the city of pontianak in what is now
indonesia founded in 1771
is said to have been the direct result
of a sultan expelling the monsters that
gave the place its name
according to the legend the first
inhabitants of the land were the
pontianak
a nobleman of arab descent traveled to
the area in the late
18th century to settle the land after
receiving it as a gift
making him its first sultan the native
pontianak did not appreciate this
intrusion to their homeland
and harass the group of settlers in an
effort to scare them off
the sultan retaliated by firing a cannon
and the loud noise drove away the ghosts
to make sure they would not return the
sultan cut down the tall trees the
pontianak called home
and used the wood to build a mosque and
his palace
to some people this story is an allegory
of the trial settlers faced attempting
to tame the dense jungle and its animal
inhabitants
but it seems a truer parallel comes from
another source of traditional folklore
pirates what would become the city of
pontianak was located at the delta of
the kapous river
a crucial point of trade for the island
of borneo
the establishment of a settlement there
to deter pirates was the official
narrative given for the sultan's
appearance
the gang of unruly ghosts was an added
bonus deterrent
this founding myth of pontianak
emphasizes the continuing tension
between the spiritual practices of the
peoples of southeast asia
like buddhism hinduism and animism
before
islam became the dominant faith animism
undoubtedly played a role in the
formation of the pontianak legend
animism is essentially the belief that
all things living
and not living have a spirit and that
the material and spiritual worlds are
not distinct
that idea is so ingrained in malay
culture that even now
regardless of religion the pontiac is
not just a monster story
but for some people it is an actual
monster
the influence of interactions between
humans and non-human beings
continues to hold deep cultural sweat
which helps explain why the ponte knock
has existed for so long
not only does she have staying power as
a cultural and historical figure
the symbolism of the pontianak and the
importance of storytelling in malaysian
culture
meant that the monster's transition from
oral folklore to film
was inevitable the horror genre has been
an important facet of the malaysian film
industry since the 1950s
films that feature spirits in the horror
genre are called hantu films
and the pontinoc made an early
appearance in these movies
however when singapore separated from
malaysia in 1965
urbanization and modern advancement made
the older traditions
like belief in the pontianak seem
antiquated and out of touch
then government censorship policies in
the late 1960s
banned the horror genre in its entirety
and pontianak films became
scarce they emerged again in the 1990s
but largely as direct to video films
and then in 2004 came the release of the
pontianak of the tuber rose
the film marked not just the return of
the pontianak to the big screen
but the return of the malaysian
blockbuster horror film itself
after the relaxation of the horror film
restrictions
mirroring many of the previous legends
of the monster the film alternates
between 1949 and the present day
showing the ponte knock in both colonial
and modern periods
as in all lore the titular character
miriam
is pregnant when her scorned lover
arranges for her to be attacked
robbed and murdered just as personified
the dead mother returns to exact revenge
on him and his family
while brutal the film is also poignant
even in the 21st century we see how
women's power is often confined and
constrained
to the very specific and limited spheres
of motherhood
victimhood sexuality male relationships
and
vengeance as more and more horror films
and novels
featuring the pontianak are made and
distributed globally
elements of malaysian culture are
becoming more broadly recognized
malaysian culture was and in many ways
still is
structured around oral tradition and
narrative storytelling
tales of the pontianak embody an entire
deeply and uniquely female journey
from loving pregnant mother to victim of
horrific violence
to vengeful wraith back to enslaved and
submissive wife
which is quite frankly a terrible cycle
this monster truly embodies so many of
the divergent and conflicting elements
of women's existence throughout history
with spirits storytelling storytelling
wrathful race but not the other way